Dr. Cutters, do you have any recommendations for intermittent fasting and food
combining? What should a breast cancer patient eat? Proteins, carbohydrates,
greens, and fruits, and wet? So you should eat what we recommended you eat on your
cheek swab test. So if you're a cheek swab test, we told you to stay away from
dairy, which is common for breast cancer, then, and that was, let's say, let's pretend
to make it simple. That was your only restriction is to stay away from dairy.
Everything else, nothing else was a driver. That's pretend only dairy was the driver.
Well, you know, you do, we give you that whole green section because, you know,
not everybody's familiar with, yeah, we've got to try to eat organic and we've got to stay away
from sugar and we've got it, you know, that, you know, all the other things that we ask you to
limit and to be careful with. And then there is another stage. There's another step you could,
everybody could go because we're only testing the cheek swab and there was the only way to do it
is to test, we lock into cancer and then see what I think is a driver or what I think you should
stay away from cancer. But there's no way to test whether you with the cheek swab, whether you have
antibodies to other foods. That's why, you know, I'm so excited for my answer patients to go and look
at the new course I have on autoimmune disease because that goes into depth on my teaching about
looking and why you'd want to look at antibodies to foods as well. Do I have antibodies to,
do I have self antibodies? And I wrote way back when I first wrote my first, first,
writing, stop fighting cancer, start treating the cause over 10 years ago, I wrote that I believe
cancer has an autoimmune component. And so that's why I've been just so driven to study autoimmune
disease and all the latest information of autoimmune diseases is in that course. So,
so the next stage, let's say I can't test it, I've been staying away from dairy. In fact,
to this question, what else could I do, you know, I'm still having other health issues, maybe it's
not even related to the cancer. Well, the next step is to do some antibody testing. And it's in that
course, in the second module where you start digging into what other testing should you do. You could
test for anti, you know, like there's another question about parasites in here is that that person
obviously may be concerned with parasites. You could do parasite testing, we could do stool parasite
testing. We could do, which would I think would be more common with cancer issues is microtoxin
testing. Microtoxins are for mold, so mold exposure. We could do glyphosate testing, which is probably
the most common with cancer. You're exposed to pesticides and herbicides. And, you know,
that'd be something to look at. Now, those things just tell you, you know, what things that we need
to continue to work on to detox, we already know those things. So, there's no need to do those testing.
The deeper thing that I'm talking about is do antibody testing to other foods because I may be,
you know, gluten might not be driving my cancer. But if it's driving in a flammatory state,
that it's very secondary, tertiary way could be driving a cancer or driving any other disease. So,
looking at antibody testing, whether you do a Syrex-2, 3x-4 or Syrex-10, those are food antibodies.
Looking at tissue antibody testing, which is a Syrex-5, and this is going over most people's heads
right now if you haven't looked at that course. But I go into detail why you'd want to do those tests.
And I know it's a lot of meeting that course, but if you could plow through that stuff,
and I'm adding stuff to that course all the time, if you can plow through that stuff,
it'll really help you understand, oh, wow, maybe this is the next step of what I could be missing
and that could be another piece to my cancer. Remember, cancer is very complex and it's
multi-faceted. So, if I could deal with it as many different facets as possible,
I'm going to have a better success. So, make sure you take the time to look at that if you can.